il est présenté comme le prochain joyau
de l'industrie ferroviaire française
le tgv du futur circulera d'ici quatre
ans la sncf a confirmé sa commande de
100 rames l'usiné alstom de belfort et
ces quelques 500 salariés planche
actuellement sur le prototype des
motrices mais rien n'assure que toutes
les locomotives sortiront des ateliers
de la cité dur
la seule garantie qu'on a de la
direction c'est que les cinq premiers
ram donc dit motrices seront fabriqués
pour la suite on nous prétexte à une
charge insuffisante pour pouvoir
maintenir le site en clair alstom doit
décrocher d'autres contrats notamment en
allemagne en ukraine pour confier
l'ensemble des locomotives du tgv du
futur à son site de belfort si ces
commandes se finalise part de la charge
ferme
nous avons une très grande probabilité
que le tgv 20 sera effectué à belfort si
ces commandes d'un beauty spa la
direction ashton fera sûrement le choix
d'effectuer la fabrication des motrices
à la rochelle la rochelle c'est
justement le site de production où
viennent d'être dévoilées les premières
pièces de l' enveloppe extérieure du
futur tgv
la direction d'alstom rappelle que le
groupe a déjà investi à belfort pour la
fabrication des locomotives le site
d'ornans devrait lui produire les
moteurs 8 pour chacune des rames
les deux usines pontoise espère bien ne
pas rater le train de cette commande à 3
milliards d'euros